[Musique]
bonsoir antoine bonsoir et on va encore
parler de l'ukraine bien sûr nouvelle un
fox concernant la guerre elle concerne
le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky oui effectivement autour d'une
vidéo en particulier qu'on va voir sur
notre écran d'ici quelques instants à
une très courte vidéo elle fait à peine
11 secondes vous la voyez ici qu'est ce
qu'on y voit une femme faire une
apparition avec une pancarte à la main
lors d'un journal télévisé et sur la
pancarte il est écrit donc j'ai dû
trouver la traduction zielinski rends
toi arrête de prendre de la drogue et
redevient un acteur un autre internaute
lui est très clair vous le voyez ici il
reprend la vidéo avec ce tweet 17 mars
sur la télévision ukrainienne il ensuite
le contenu de la pancarte avant de
conclure aucune information sur cette
manifestation dans les médias
occidentaux évidemment c'est vrai qu'en
tout cas sur le papier l'intervention a
l'air en tout cas séduisante un autre
hit internautes italiens lui cette fois
il voit une imitation du geste de la
journaliste russe souvenez-vous marina
officielles mikko va vous le voyez il
affirme que cela s'est passé pendant un
journal télévisé de la chaîne eut créé
in à à 24 marine a officié nicolas on ne
souvient elle avait dénoncé soulève une
invasion russe de l'ukraine en
brandissant une pancarte dont on voit
ici une capture d'écran en plein journal
télévisé elle avait ensuite quitté la
chaîne après avoir été arrêtés du coup
suite à cet événement alors voilà pour
le contexte revenons à notre vidéo est
ce qu'elle est vrai est ce qu'elle est
fausse et bien un peu des deux la vidéo
provient d'un conte tik tok le voici
d'une certaine olga stiffer vous la
voyez c'est une ukrainienne et elle
propose de courtes vidéos sur un ton
humoristique il faut bien dire qu'elle
rencontre un certain succès voyait là
elle a un peu plus de 33000 abonnés
voici une autre capture d'écran de la
vidéo en elle-même qu'elle a postée elle
même sur son compte et elle a précisé en
commentaire que bien évidemment il
s'agissait d'une vidéo tournée sur un
fond vert la chaîne ukrainienne en
revanche en question elle existe bel et
bien je vous ai trouvé ici son site
internet une krajina 24 qui propose une
émission baptisée freedom c'est son nom
qu'on aperçoit dans la vidéo les
programmes de la chaîne peu n'ont pas
été on interrompt interrompue 14 mars la
date de soi de la soi-disant
intervention nous avons vérifié c'est
donc bien un détournement là où ça
devient intéressant audrey section le
profil de cette femme que je vous ai
présenté elle est ouvertement anti
zelensky on l'a vu on l'a vu dans la
dans la vidéo sur celle ci par exemple
qu'une autre capture d'écran que j'ai
trouvé pour vous c'est une courte vidéo
là encore on la voit se moquer de
l'intervention du président aziz qui
dans les rues de kiev ici à l'équipe des
observateurs d'ailleurs on doute
d'ailleurs qu'il s'agisse de son vrai
nom sans pour autant pouvoir le vérifier
là où c'est encore plus intéressant
c'est que cette dame propose également
une pâle une chaîne télégramme que vous
voyez ici elle propose des publications
à tendance pro russe il faut bien le
dire à l'exemple de cette vidéo est un
montage de zorro vous savez euros voilà
on entend la célèbre générique de la
série euros avec évidemment la lettre z
qui apparaît lettres devenue symbole
vous le savez désormais de ralliement
des pro russe et elle la publie avec le
commentaire ci dessous je ne sous-entend
rien mais j'ai le sentiment qu'ils vont
bientôt censuré cette vidéo sur une
autre vidéo celle ci par exemple que je
ne vais pas vous jouez elle se moque de
l'homme que vous voyez juste à droite
dans le commentaire s'il s'agit du vice
ministre ukrainien de l'intérieur qui
affirmait que poutine était un lâcher à
l'aigle elle ajoute ici dans les
commentaires que l'on voit en dessous
c'est exact ce eux sont si courageux qui
l'ont été les premiers à fuir l'ukraine
et à rejoindre le front du canapé enfin
l art partagé une photo que je vais vous
vous retrouvez un petit peu plus loin
voilà vous la voyez celle-ci de ces de
cet homme et de cette femme en costume
traditionnel
cette femme que vous apercevez ici il
s'agit de l'opposante russe ciena
sobczak à côté d'un ukrainien et elle
met en ce commentaire que l'on trouve
juste au dessus ici elle dit yves bény
car à ce qu'est l'homme qu'on aperçoit à
côté de cette dame est un nazi membres
du groupe ces 14 donc voila vous le
conte vous l'avez compris une
personnalité tu roules audrey sous
couvert d'un ton humoristique on
retrouve les éléments de langage plus
critique de volodymyr zelensky
accusations de lâcheté des ukrainiens et
bien sûr présence de en ukraine
influence euse donc on l'aura compris
mais visiblement bien militante aussi
sur la position russe merci beaucoup
antoine fenaux rester avec nous on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
nouveau journal dans ce paris direct
[Musique]